soll ich glaube ich muss mein café
erstmal austrinken
aber da seht ihr mal dass ich auch mal
fans passieren sehr oft sogar
alles ist irgendwie so alles kommt auf
einmal heute am ende keiner wird was
merken da haben sie mit nichts merken
das ist wunderschön aussehen
mai zusammen wir waren heute diese
wunderschön und sehr sehr leckeren
kuchen kuchen städten am stiel falls
solche namen schreibt gerne in die
kommentare ich bin noch unsicher und in
diesem video war das so ich habe sie
irgendwo mann aufgestockt auf tik tok
und haben eigentlich dekolleté zwei so
kekse dann mit creme dann scheint alles
mit einem cache pop steht in diesem
video ist aber ein bisschen was schief
gegangen und ich habe es jetzt wir haben
es jetzt einfach so geschnitten wir
haben es hochgeladen und alles drin
gelassen ihr wisst ja normalerweise
teste ich rezepte vorher guckt was man
beachten muss et cetera aber ich hab
gedacht so spontan ist auch mal ganz
cool und jetzt möchte ich euch hier
sprache video es geht jetzt hier
zuallererst mascarpone in die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt eure
handrührgerät benutzen es waren ja immer
ganz viele das ist gar kein problem ihr
braucht halt wirklich nur eine minute
länger so da gebe ich jetzt direkt sahne
mit dazu achte darauf dass alle zutaten
schön kalt sind dann lässt sich das
nämlich auch schon steif schlagen soll
für die süße gebe ich eigentlich nur
noch ein mini bisschen puderzucker dazu
und dann kommt bei mir noch meine
schokocreme mit dem zuge könnt euren
lieblings aufstrich nehmen weil es
natürlich dieser hier und das kommt dann
auch noch mit dazu dann schlage ich das
alles mit dem schneebesen aussetzt und
laster fest ein riesen
[Musik]
die leckere creme habe ich mir schon mal
in einem großen spritzbeutel gefüllter
werde ich gleich auch noch einen spitze
abschneiden einfach damit es einfacher
ist zum befüllen und ich werde jetzt
aber vorab einmal die kuvertüre
vorbereitet ich habe jetzt die formkurve
türe ihr könnt auch zart bitter nehmen
oder weiße kuvertüre das ist ganz nach
eurem geschmack tapezier aber auch schon
ein wasserbad vorbereitet das heißt
einmal wasser zum kochen bringen und
einen topf obendrüber stellen und da
gebe ich jetzt erstmal zwei drittel der
kuvertüre rein und lassen es schön
langsam schmelzen so weit ist alles
geschmolzen ist nämlich sand vom herd
und gibt dann einfach nur noch das
restliche drittel dazu das dient dazu
dass wir später kein grauschleier haben
und dass die kuvertüre richtig schön
bands
[Musik]
ich glaube ich muss mein café erstmal
aus trinken
weil ich habe nämlich nicht mitgedacht
ich habe jetzt alles schön hier mit
diesem tag boxstil also ich habe quasi
erst mal ein cache boxstil in die
kuvertüre gedruckt und dann auf den keks
gelegt aber
ich dolly ich habe jetzt alle quasi mit
dem kopf spielen belegt was natürlich du
willst weil eigentlich brauchen wir noch
ein deckel das heißt die mache ich
einfach gleich wieder ab aber ihr seht
ihr mal dass ich auch mal fans passieren
sehr oft sogar und die mache ich gleich
einfach ab und dann lege ich das quasi
als decke oben drüber ich habe jetzt
auch im gefrierschrank getan könnte auch
im kühlschrank machen dort noch ein paar
minuten länger einfach damit dies
beschleunige damit die kuvertüre fest
ihr denn jetzt kann man das quasi
anheben und jetzt nehmen wir uns wieder
unsere leckere schokocreme dem bis quasi
immer auf den keks ich mache mir nur
noch ein bisschen platz dann kommt der
deckel drauf und dann könnt ihr es
entweder noch mal kühlen wenn ihr merkt
wie creme ist nicht ganz so fest oder
ihr verarbeitet es direkt weiter ich
kann dir immer dazu kühlt lieber nochmal
moment damit ist dann anschließend hier
in die temperierte kuvertüre rein tun
könnt und anschließend mal schlechte
kopie ich sogar noch mit der industrie
um das wäre dann nämlich ein schöner
kontrast oder gibt da einfach noch
gekannt oder so was drauf
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wen sind aufgefallen es
wer hat hier die adleraugen die creme
ist riesig geworden was passiert wenn
eine creme gruselig ist eigentlich
nichts außer dass es wirklich fünf oder
zehn sekunden zu lange geschlagen wurde
und dadurch ja sieht man halt so das ist
nicht ganz das muss nicht ganz so glatt
tut das was im geschmack nein gar nicht
irgendwas in der in der festigkeit oder
so auch nicht es ist wirklich nur das
aussehen und da seht ihr mal wirklich
heute es geht auch bei mir manchmal
einiges schief ich war irgendwie auf dem
falschen fuß aufgestockt hat auch ein
bad hair day alles ist irgendwie so
alles kommt auf einmal heute aber leut
ich sag's euch am ende keiner wird was
merken da haben sie mit nichts merken es
ist wunderschön aussehen wie stress
jetzt hier am besten noch mal so mit
einem messer alles schön glatt und dann
könnte das einfach in die in die
kuvertüre tunken also ich habs jetzt
nicht gekühlt ich muss sagen irgendwie
es meine creme recht fest aber wenn ihr
euch unsicher seid einfach 10 20 minuten
in den kühlschrank geben und gibt auch
bitte nicht zu viel creme rein weil
sonst wird das nicht mehr standfest also
nicht so übertreiben wird einfach hier
rein drucken und dann könnt ihr euch auf
jeden fall schon mal ein backpapier
bereit legen denn es kommt jetzt auf
backpapier und dann könnte es auch
nochmal versetzen damit ja
damit also keine schoko füße ja ich
mache ja heute irgendwie
ich denke immer dass kühlt lieber noch
mal also ich kühe die kleben noch mal
und dann mache ich das ganze in rohr
soll muss sich da schon ein bisschen
zeit für nehmen
[Musik]
das sind jetzt die fertigen meisterwerke
ich muss eigentlich für die echt schön
ich bin froh dass ich das gemacht habe
trotz höhen und tiefen heute im video
worauf man wirklich achten muss ist dass
man das lange genug kühlt nimmt und
immer wieder zeit für die kühe zeiten
vor allem damit eben der stil recht
stabil bleibt bei der kuvertüre die
wurde ja temperiert das ist also gar
kein problem wenn ihr dann wirklich ab
und zu mal zehn minuten ins gefrierfach
oder den kühlschrank die kuvertüre
bleibt so wie sie ist das ist nämlich
der vorteil an temperierte kuvertüre die
wir dann auch nicht so schnell wieder
fest ansonsten könnt ihr dekorieren wie
ihr möchtet für die lagerung würde ich
sagen lagers ruhig im kühlschrank und am
besten schmeckt das wenn das wirklich
die ganze feuchtigkeit von der creme
aufgezogen aufgesogen wird und ja
ansonsten ganz viel spaß für nachmachen
und ich sage jetzt schon mal bis zum
nächsten mal auf die skizzen und peter
las diesem video einen daumen nach oben
wenn euch diese art von videos auch
gefällt schock folgen sprach wieder
sondern sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
scheiße ich hatte mein mikrofon hier
drin verstehe
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob's geräusch hallt es
passt zum heutigen tag ich habe viel
schweiß tropft verstehen ganz verrückten
ist nass ich hatte mein mikrofon hier
drehen es tut mir etwas grau statt also
da sind cool aus
ich überlege mal wieder draußen
ich glaube man wird es für 192 verkaufen
und könnte gut durchziehen jetzt ist der
ausnahmestimme und innen cherokee mit
einer sammlung mascarpone creme
eigentlich hätte stehen sollen aber
immer wieder gebraucht aber
jetzt wo der keks auch so weich ist das
nach dem
5 die 19 warum so neuen passiert jetzt
gefehlt 14 die messe hatte einfach
überlegen bis 2010 sollen davon dieses
kleine bisschen aber dass man schon gut
gehen das ist richtig das ist richtig
politik ist es besser als frau enke für
den auftritt denn für den test ist und
bis zum nächsten mal
nein